so guys it's great to see you at the
premiere for the raid two here at
Sundance Film Festival tonight how much
are you looking forward to seeing on
that big screen with a massive crowd
well we're very excited to be here I
mean it's our first time being here and
we're very excited to see how the people
will react to the movie
Iko how does it compare working on this
one to the first rate is a different
gasser maybe for the brand alike the
rate to it like more more push for me
and all of group how much more punishing
has it been as well in terms of the
action London choreography it was much
more complex so yeah it was much more
challenging for all of us I'm liking
drama so yeah much more drama in the
first one yeah because they were there's
more of a story in the second one
did he tell us a little bit more about
your character in the film um well I'm
playing the role of hammer girl
basically she's a cold-blooded assassin
trained assassin and yeah having no
backgrounds of martial arts at all I had
to train for six months where I did
hours and hours of trainings almost
every day and yeah I was very
challenging but exciting at the same
time how helpful then was it working
with someone like Eko who just have such
a big background in that and and what
did you do to help Julie as well well it
was very exciting to work with
Eko because he's very helpful actually
he was helped me a lot throughout all
the Fighting's and I actually have a
fighting scene with him and it was very
exciting you know I mean especially for
me having no backgrounds of martial arts
having to fight with him and he's been
fighting since what since he was three
years old so it was very challenging for
me but yeah he was very helpful and he
made me comfortable yeah exactly we have
a team for choreo team for choreography
fight like minion and ferry Yandy and
plantain also and yeah we practice
together and even like Julie's never
practice with martial art but she can do
it for everything like really good
pretty stuff now how much in terms of
cuz obviously with the name like hammer
girl it's kind of like a little bit
comic book kind of character how much of
an element is there of that in the film
and with your character well I think it
is a bit comical where I have to fight
with hammers I mean it's pretty unique
you know you don't find that every day
new everyday life but yeah I think
that's what's been really interesting in
this movie is that there are so many
different characters like baseball bat
man where he fights with a baseball bat
there's the assassin that fights and we
all have different tools to fight and
that's pretty comical I guess now how
was it fighting that big scene in the
mud in the prison it's a it's really
difficult for us for me and fights out
the fighter because uh
Madonna because this that I guess yeah
that is really really like sleepy and
like it look like you had what about 50
fighters 100 fighters 5550 fighters in
that set
it's really crowded and yeah it has to
be like that all together I guess it was
pretty complicated
you also had Eugene Garrett's very first
car chase scene as well weren't you how
is that oh it's different as well
because you know like I have to fight
with the five people inside the car like
really complex like still still good
with the movement right but the space is
really small but yeah like thanks God we
can do it like scutella now we know
obviously it's a great drama in the film
but there's lots of action scenes as
well how many wounds did you have how
many war wounds did you have at the end
of the film all of it I don't know I
said but I had like all over my body I
mean have I mean you know not being used
to doing physical things it was very
challenging and ya had bruises
everywhere but I guess it it came with
it I mean when I decided to take this
part I just knew it was the consequences
so yeah it was fun though hmmm let me
like use it oh maybe like for like
bruises is fine but maybe it's hard it's
really hard we hurt no we know you can
look forward to not only the road too
but also the r83 and we cannot wait what
would you like to see happen ideally in
that third movie in the trilogy
maybe more like dramatic and not like
complex but the choreo but like complex
about the drama drama scene and you
might like to see him get a little bit
of a rest as well maybe yeah maybe but
but still yeah maybe how long do you
think we'll be to see hammer girl come
back again well I don't know about the
rate three I would I would love to be a
part of the third movie but yeah we'll
see maybe I'll try to get Gareth to you
know yeah and get me a new character in
the third movie we'll see
see now I'm finally know you've got
another movie coming up with both Gareth
and Timo haven't you so tell me a little
bit about that well I wouldn't want to
spoil me but it's it it's um it's
another action movie it's I mean it's
another challenge for me because it's
going to be action full action but it's
different than hammer girl because
hammer girl is a bit based on Selah
whereas this new character is really
full action with like guns and it's a
different kind of fighting so it'll be a
new New York more universally like the
movement right how about for you go I'm
like behind behind the scenes he's gonna
be one of the trainers you're gonna have
to be working everyone really really
hard then yeah yeah yeah also guys have
a fantastic time tonight weren't you
really great to meet you
you